so now it's my uh great pleasure to
introduce antonina kolakolova uh
antonina is one of those theorists who
is interested in many different things
not only proof complexity but also in
the practical side of uh you know
solvers for example so
i've had the pleasure of working with
her on many papers together
and she's also interested in the
connections between theory and
neuroscience
she's well known for her work improved
complexity
and she did her phd under the
supervision of stephen cook
and is currently a professor at memorial
university of newfoundland
so without further ado antonina please
go ahead
thank you so much for the nice
introduction with ray
okay so um
and uh thank you so much albert and
benedict for spectacular talks it was so
cool to listen to you
[Music]
okay so uh what i'm going to talk about
is uh one more line of connections kind
of in the opposite direction
from what benedict talked about
not from proof complexity into
um fine model theory
well with proving things and going back
but
uh how we could take
results in descriptive complexity and
actually build reasoning systems on top
of them
so basically uh we have
uh kind of three realms in which you
talk about
problems one of them is the search
problems
for example how hard it is to find a
path in a graph
another one the one that you've just
heard a lot about
is uh expressive power what does it take
to say
that the graph is connected
but at the third side uh the one that
showed up more improved systems
what does it take to prove properties
for example that
reachability strategy
and the loosely speaking
those three realms would be your
classical graceman
complexity theory descriptive complexity
and type model theory
and for the probability of
proof systems as well as its uniform
counterpart
bounded arithmetic and you've seen a lot
about the
relation between complexity and the
find model theory today descriptive
complexity
you've seen uh some of
uh translation from proof systems
into descriptive complexity in
benedict's talk
and actually next week uh in this
workshop next wednesday we are going to
have a session
on um kind of mathematical foundations
of that with stocks going
more into arithmetic and um
probability and that side of thing so
what i
want to talk about today is
um is how
uh results proven in bound
in descriptive complexity setting
can let us build something
in
let us build reasoning systems
so it's this direction
so um just one caveat
that here i'm just going to talk about
the uniform classes and uniform system
there was a really nice question about
non-uniform
side of finite model theory but
what i want to focus on today is
actually uniform side
of finite model theory because to me in
a way
some of those characterizations that
albert talked about
are uniform counterparts to what we
think about
us the prepositional satisfiability
problem
and friends and in fact um pagan theorem
is kind of a counterpart
of cook's theorem where rather than
getting a class of formulas
you just get one formal uniform setting
so um and another thing between
uniformity we will be talking about
uniform classes even for very small
classes so we could talk about the class
uniform deluxe time uniform ac 0
which has a very direct connection with
first order logic
so more precisely uh
and i will define those things um
what i want to show today is how you
could start with
um logics in particular fragments of
second order logic
this nice descriptive complexity
characterization
and use them to build theories
with the same power
and show what exactly
you need to get theories of the same
power from those characterizations
so you just heard albert stock
and he was talking about the
groundbreaking
result in 74 of
uh ron pagan who've shown
that np corresponds precisely to
existential second order
and the proof is again a variant
of hook theorem except rather than
generating a different formula
for different input and
random detuning machine you actually
have just one formula
defining the tableau of the computation
and the this allows you to be
in a setting where you could actually
talk about
one formula specifying a problem as
opposed to a family
of problems so for example in proof
complexity we often talk about
pigeonhole principle as a family
but here pigeonhole principle is just a
single formula
okay so um
thickness characterization shows that
without any assumptions
on the underlying structure um
np corresponds to existential second
order formulas
in 1991 regradle extended it
to show that subclasses
of second order logic in particular
second order logic
where the formulas are of this form
also correspond to
well-defined complexity classes on
structures containing successors so in
particular
if you take existential second order
formula
of this form and you restrict
the formula to be a horn formula
uh where i guess the horn with respect
to those
p1 to pk predicates then
on successful structure this logic
captures
exactly polynomial time and when you
restrict the formula to b2cnf
you could capture non-deterministic
log space and actually he had
characterization for symmetric work
space for lock space
it's a it's really beautiful piece of
work
can you uh define what you mean meant by
um horn over
the predicates uh so i just mean that
it's a cnf formula where every clause
has at most
one positive uh occurrence of a
predicate
okay got it so you only consider those
as occurrences of the predicate as your
variables
to say and then it's horn with respect
to that
so another result uh by
barrington immerman and strobin i think
there might have been
some earlier results by immerman but
barrington
when strobing gives a deluxe time
uniform characterization
shows that if you don't have second
order quantifiers
then uh you just have first order logic
with three second order variables
then you capture exactly the class
ac 0 the class of bounded depth circuits
which is probably the smallest
complexity class
that you hear people talking about
and the beauty of those
characterizations is that
the correspondence is exact if you prove
the two logics are equivalent the
corresponding classes are
and vice versa so as albert was
showing there are lots of techniques
that can be applied in this setting
to prove something about logic and then
transfer it
well to proof systems and so on
so in proof complexity
we tend to be more interested in
proving tautology so proving some
statement
uh rather than expressing statements
and natural question is
if you are operating with a class of
formulas
with precisely defined complexity can
you say something about the complexity
of
reasoning with those formulas
and um actually to me it goes
way back to the time when i was
undergraduate
and i came to tony pitasi
uh asking to do some research with her
and she gave me
two papers one of them was ron fagan's
finite models theory personal
perspective
and another one was sambas notes
on bounded charismatic
so i read them got very excited came to
tony and say
tony so how do those two how are those
related
how do you go from one to the other
there must be a connection well i'm
still stuck thinking about the
connection
many many years after
so let me just mention very few things
about the
history of the arithmetic side of it
and next week we are going to have
several talks
that will cover this much better and in
much more detail
by uh sasha rasbora pavel pudlak
and so
i won't spend too much time on it but uh
basically um piano arithmetic is
probably one
theory that people think about when they
think about um
power of reasoning in um
power of reasoning in systems unless you
do
bound uh at least you do reverse
mathematica or something like that piano
is
is one of the default theories that we
written about
and um later on
people have defined uh so but um indian
arithmetic is very strong
it talks about things from computability
real
rather than complexity realm um in order
to move things to
closer to the efficiency question parikh
defined the bounded version
of an arithmetic ideal to zero
but this time it ended up being series a
little bit too weak you just talk
about linear time hierarchy and you
can't quite go beyond it
then uh steve cook have defined the
theory pv original as an equational
theory
which was designed to capture polynomial
time
exactly he used cobon's characterization
of polar male time recursive
characterization to just
define polynomial time functions and
operations for them
this theory would later extend that
thing by criteria to make
to add a bit more blind stuff
and um probably one of the main
defining works in this area
is sunburst's beautiful scissors called
bounded arithmetic
where he defined um
well he defined a lot of different
theories
corresponding to various complexity
classes
and proved very interesting witnessing
theorem
that is proved that when you can prove
something
in theory then you know the
complex if you prove an existential
statement in the theory
with certain form then finding a
business
can be done by an algorithm of specific
complexity and the algorithm kind of
falls out of the proof
so uh well in bounded arithmetic just to
say
uh what makes it bounded is that they're
thinking of
all values that are quantified as
bounded by the terms in the three
variables
and uh here when i'm talking about the
power of a serial
arithmetic especially in the
correspondence with
complexity classes it's basically what
kind of
functions can be
probably defined in the system by
um
can be defined in this system so the the
system proves
there exists unique value of the
function
and just one caveat uh that
it can very well happen that there are
theories that capture
the same class of functions
that is a proof totality of the same
class of functions
and yet one system seems to be more
powerful than
another system as in
it's not believed to be that everything
every theorem that one system proves can
be proved in the other
so relating this back to prepositional
proof systems
uh there is actually a very direct
connection
because uh for those kinds of theories
for one direction you could do
you could do a direct translation in
propositional proof systems by
taking theorems of the cis
of the theory converting them into your
family of tautologies
and showing that the corresponding proof
system can prove that family of
pathology
and for the other direction you could
show that
the bounded arithmetic theory can
prove essentially soundness
more precisely reflection principle for
the corresponding proof system
so even though um bounded arithmetic is
a kind of a uniform
setting and proof systems are
non-uniform there is a very tight
connection between the two
and uh just to mention that you
the theory that captures
ac zero would give a translation
directly into
ac zero fragment bounded that's trigger
similarly a theory for um nc one will
give you
frag and the theories for polynomial
time
they translate in this way to extended
fraction
okay so
let's now connect the descriptive
complexity side
and bound the charismatic side
by showing how you could build a theory
of arithmetic
and if you have never seen a theory of
arithmetic or built one
hopefully this would be a kind of a
gentle introduction to one way of doing
it
so what we need in the theory we need a
language
and we need axioms and here
we are going to take a slightly
different
path from what sambas did in his thesis
and use a two-sorted theory which will
have a much better correspondence to the
descriptive complexity characterization
what i mean by to sorted is that you
have two kinds of objects
you have numbers and you have strings
just like
in distributive complexity
characterization you have your
graphs predicates as being the
second order object so to say floating
rounds
here you will have strings corresponding
to
the structures
and the axioms of the theory
would be fairly standard first of all
for numbers we'll just take
the very classic axioms defining how
plus and time separates and here we just
need plus and times
for example axiom saying that
for any x x plus one is not equal to
zero
and um and stuff like that
one is greater than zero and so on
then for strings we will have very few
things
again we want to look at them as
predicates so
we will just say um
we will just use an operator telling us
what the bit of a string
is and we also defined what the length
of the string is because we want to kind
of bounce things so we want to say
um
can you hear me i can hear you clearly
antonina uh is there anybody else who
wants to just say that
whether they can hear i can hear you
okay
thank you so i guess thomas is having
some problems there
maybe it's yeah
okay
okay so um
in addition to those basic axioms saying
what you could do with strings and what
you could do with numbers
well add and multiply numbers and take a
length of the string and look up a bit
there is one more axiom and this is this
will be the main
um axiom that will let us define
all sorts of different theories and
basically what this axiom is saying
is that if you have a formula
some limited class or formulas
then you could get a characteristic
string
of that formula that's
really the only thing that we need to
build the theory
and now
we could reason with those axioms and in
order to do reasoning in order to do
proof
uh you could take your favorite way of
doing proof
i think uh gunson's calculus lk
is the most standard underlying day of
doing proof but
there is really um so
can i ask you a quick question x of y
what is what does that notation mean is
x a string here and
y is a number uh yeah it just uh
uh the wise bit of x when x is treated
as string
okay so you're saying if i
take the white bit of x then it implies
y must be you kind of interpret one as a
true and the
zero the false
so uh another way of thinking about it
is x is a set and
x of y is whether y is in the set x
i see you see okay
and uh comprehension you're saying there
exists a string
x x is a string variable
uh i'm trying to is less than or equal
to
n so i guess the bit strings
here are being interpreted as numbers
implicitly
um well the strings are strings numbers
are mainly used to
talk about lengths and indices yeah but
but
what do you mean there exists an x less
than or equal to n what is that oh
sorry i didn't define this notation uh
so
thank you so much so what i mean is
lengths of x
less than equal to n okay so there
exists an x such that
length of x is less than or equal to n
for all
uh integer variables or natural numbers
z less than n
so now if z is in the set x
uh i say c c c okay
all right
got it but here but here
fee is a formula in this language or is
it a formula of over arithmetic
it's a formula in in whatever restricted
class of formulas we define
and the power of the theory will
correspond to the power of that class of
formulas
okay
yes thank you more questions comments
nope please go ahead
so um one thing that you might be
wondering is
there is induction because in piano
arithmetic and pretty much
pretty much all the other theories that
i've seen vast majority of them
you have an induction axon in fact you
could actually
for all the theories that we care about
prove induction but just
just to have it to make life easier
here it is uh given a string you could
do
induction on the length of the string so
if something
um if x of 0
well if element 0 is in the set x if you
want to think about it as set
and for every y if y isn't
the set x then y plus 1 is then
n is in the set x here's your induction
on the length of the string
so this is really all you need to build
the theory
and you don't even need induction and
now with those theories um
you could prove theorems you could uh
define functions and proof totalities of
the functions
you can convert them to proof systems
and so on
so um what kind of theories do we get
when
we do it for different so what defines
the power of the theory is really
what class of formulas we are allowed
the theory is allowed to talk about
so um first of all if we take
um other class of formulas
um existential second order and here
um i'm treating the second of
order objects in the descriptive
complexity setting just as strings
in bounded arithmetic setting but this
really doesn't matter the translation
the translation pretty direct so if you
take existential second order you get
the logical np predicates and
if you make a theory out of existential
second order
you make a theory that can talk
about um well things definable by np
predicts
and in particular you get
you directly get two sorted analogs of
some buses hierarchy s
s2 but here's the interesting thing
um sambas proved a beautiful
theorem about the theory
that operates with as
so exist predicates
and the theorem says that if
within the theory uh
you could prove that
well the function is definable the
predicate is np intercept currently
so there is also exist and so for all
formulas
and
they equivalently define the predicate
then in fact you get that
the predicate the function isn't
polynomial time
it's really really beautiful result
and kind of surprising it basically says
that if you reason
with np predicates and if you can prove
that something is an np-intercept point
then in fact it must be in polynomial
time
so sort of in the bounded arithmetic
world at least here
the probability intercept point p is
polynomial time
a really cool really surprising result
and this naturally generalizes two
levels of polynomial time hierarchy
you could talk about exists for all
exist
a second order and it will give you a
third level
and again you could use the weaknesses
theorem
by fitness and theorem to capture the
corresponding
um deterministic class
but you may ask the okay with np
predicates we didn't quite capture np
what we really captured is polynomial
time
in the case when the theory could prove
that something is in an intersect
point but can they actually take
a logic corresponding to a complexity
class and get a theory
for exactly the same complexity class
what would it take
uh so before we go that just to quickly
mention for
people who are familiar with uh some
buses theories
um the different the difference here is
that
in our language we only have plus and
times but we do
have um strings
so some already had theories
the second order object he defined
series for
p space for exponential time and so on
and there he used that extra
function in the language in order to
define bigger things
but um red boro and security have shown
that you can go
back and forth between the series with
one more
extra sword and um
having this smash operator in the
language
so in our setting we don't have any
extra operators
uh and they just have the string sword
and
we get that this is equivalent to s3
okay so just to reiterate
how do we get the theory we take axioms
define in basic arithmetic and add an
axiom that says
all objects definable in a certain logic
exist
so what can we do with it
we could actually extend uh so um
if i didn't the theories
uh s i2 and ti2 that sambas define
um there you do allow multiplication
on big number small numbers so you
generally have multiplication
but in the setting here in the
two-sorted setting
you since you don't have multiplication
of the
larger second order object you could
actually
get a theory for ac 0 but you cannot
do multiplication of your objects and
starting from the theory for ac 0
you could get a series for
all sorts of classes within polynomial
time
and how do you get a theory for ac c0
well remember that barnes and nimmerman
strobing
told us the first order logic
if you have arithmetic in your language
and well you have arithmetic in your
language
in arithmetic captures
d log time uniform ac zero so
just define
uh our class of formulas to be uh
formulas with non-second order
quantifiers
and uh using beautiful characterization
by error gradle we get a theory for
non-deterministic log space and the
theory for polynomial time
from second order uh existential to
siena formulas and
second order existential horn formulas
respectively
but this correspondence
is not exactly automatic because
remember if we had
np formulas we didn't really
quite get np we got polynomial time
and this is really non-trivial result
when do we actually capture precisely
theory
and this depends on how hard it is to
prove
closure properties of the complexity
class
so what do what do i mean by quarter
properties
we would like to work with really nice
complexity classes and nice complexity
class of which
np is not quite are closed under first
order operations
you could take ends and ors and notes
and bounded quantification you can
compose things
and you still remain within the class so
um in particular for np it's a very good
question whether it's
closed under uh negation let alone
whether it's probably close under
negation so
np and classes and the polynomial time
hierarchy
are not really quite robust to get those
kind of results
but polynomial time non-deterministic
log space
non-trivial and ac 0 definitely are
and another caveat is that we really
want those properties to be provable
within the reasoning in the system
so and here it is it's a generic
statement
that if you could actually prove
using reasoning with only concept from
that class
that the class is closed under
first order operations then
um you get a system of arithmetic that
precisely captures this complexity class
as in it proves um totality exactly of
the functions
from this class so this gives you an
automatic way to take
a logic characterization of a complexity
class
whichever one your favorite complexity
class is
and convert it into a theory of
arithmetic
so uh i'm really out of time but let me
just say
for ac 0 it's direct ac 0 is close than
the ac 0
for polynomial time and for nl it's a
bit more work because
you actually need to formalize foreign
satisfiability in the process analytical
cornell
within and our reasoning within polytime
reasoning
but this can be done it even trickier
class
um log cfl sac one
was done by satoru roda
and um yeah
and basically the way you do it is you
build the theory
and then you generalize uh
bus fitness and theorem to the new
setting
so just to say that not the only way of
building
theories for example um you can go in
in their book they also
use an approach of taking a complete
problem
for a class and throwing it in as an
axiom defining action for that problem
and then building theories on that
but um
generally at least you could definitely
translate from um
from descriptive complexity okay
um so i'm out of time
so let me just say that this
this talk was mostly kind of a survey
from this week's topic i find models
here in descriptive complexity to next
week's
topics which will touch upon
many different aspects of reasoning
systems in particular i think systems of
arithmetic
from piano arithmetic to bounded
arithmetic
but uh hopefully um
here um you could
see how you could go from the power
from the expressive power to reasoning
power
in essentially in one method
thank you so much and any questions
comments
awesome thank you for a beautiful and
enlightening talk antenna thank you very
much
questions please
so so i have some comments and uh
questions so
in a different setting i actually study
theories over
arithmetic and strings and i'm surprised
that there is this
uh i wasn't aware of this these theories
over strings and arithmetic that
were defined by cook and others
and i would be happy to chat with you
offline about potential connections
because there are many open questions
there
which have been open for maybe 70 years
or something like that
and i wonder whether any of these
connections can be helpful
in resolving some of those questions
some of them are complexity
theoretic because others are more you
know decidability
you know and so on but in any event
it would be interesting to you know
explore those connections
um any additional questions
yeah i have one question about this
sl equals l result so
the existence of expander graphs you do
it with the zigzag product
there's a kind of zigzag yeah
so which part is missing to get the
formalization
is it drops yeah what's missing is that
the you could prove the existence of
expanded graphs when you start with
things small things with constant
expansion and you combine them
you keep expansion constant what you do
when you start with something that does
not have a constant expansion
that's what we haven't figured out
okay
hi antonina uh can you comment on these
two approaches
uh you mentioned i cooked new a and
your approach using finite model theory
uh so what are the differences between
let's say the theories you get for nl by
doing such things
like is is there an easy way to or are
they exactly the same to prove the same
theorem so what exactly happens
they do prove the same theorems
um i i think steve has
stephen fong having their book the
connections
all the different ways but they i think
as far as i know they do prove the same
theorems
so even the theory operating with uh
horn formula does prove the same series
as pv but interestingly it's much easier
to formalize
the recursive definition using the horn
formula than go the other way around
any additional questions so i'm trying
to put together a question
so for antonita so i was struck by the
same thing that encore mentioned that
you
you split your you were categorizing
things that
introduced all functions all at once
versus things that sort of built up to
get all functions i've always
categorized more the first order
theories versus the second order
theories
so we sort of have two two different
viewpoints of this does this mean
there's really three different
ways to set up bound bound arithmetic do
you view it this way
um i'm taking over your paper with steve
on chrome and so forth and
uh with um proving so uh
proving that and that nl equals cohen l
that's a that's a different type of
bootstrapping you think than
the things that the theories use
induction
um that's a different type of
bootstrapping um yes but
you you would know much better than i do
what does a different face
well i mean i've certainly read all this
i just never it's just you obviously
have a bit different
viewpoint of this i was interested to
get your your feeling about this
um so
you can definitely start with um an
axiom that
gives you a totality of for example
graph reachability or circuit evaluation
problem
and build theory on top of it and you
end up with nice theory
universally axiomatizing everything
and i think you could prove the
equivalence um
between this theory and the theory based
on
um the descriptive complexity
view and um
and the theories like pv that come from
the
definitions as
far as i know they're equivalent but as
there's a very good way of saying that
you did you need a different type of
bootstrapping
in each case
okay good good i guess the other comment
is you
seems seemingly we need to go to the
second order versions of the theories to
deal with these very weak classes like
l and l and nl and so forth and
sac-1 i suppose and so forth
i get just because we get ac1
since we don't have multiplication of
the larger objects
right so yeah
and going from descriptive complexity to
second order is a bit more
kind of it's a bit easier than
at least for me to think about because
in descriptive complexity you do have
those
second order objects floating around
okay all right all right thank you thank
you thank you again antonina for a
wonderful talk
thank you so thanks to all the speakers
for great talks thank you
thank you to everybody and i guess we
will be on the town at least some of us
after this soon yeah all right
so see you tomorrow then bye bye
everybody
okay thank you so much
thank you fantastic fantastic talk
thanks